german chancellor olaf schultz has said
he plans to meet with russian president
vladimir putin to discuss tensions over
ukraine schultz has been facing pressure
to take a tougher stance on russia with
critics accusing germany of being out of
step with its allies in tackling the
crisis he's now trying to reassure
people that germany is indeed pulling
its weight
of course i have also spoken with the
russian president and of course we are
carefully preparing everything that
needs to be done
i will now be going to the us and i will
be continuing the conversation on the
necessary issues in moscow soon
it's important that the policies of the
european union and nato are coordinated
but it's also important that the
decisions that we take are the result of
sound preparation and hard work
speaking there and uh political
correspondent julia sardelli is standing
by for some analysis julia what's known
about the upcoming visit of the
chancellor to moscow
we don't have that many details uh shell
said it would happen soon so we expect
it maybe to happen
after
schultz's trip to
washington dc to meet with president joe
biden which is happening at the
beginning of next week
schultz has said that he has been in
communication with putin and this is an
important point because there um is some
in dissatisfaction in germany with
schultz's role with schultz's presence
uh some say he's sort of been missing an
action in the last few days and so he
had to make clear that yes he is in
communication with putin and yes he is
working on uh trying to find a peaceful
solution to the tensions in the
situation between russia and uh ukraine
and this visit to putin comes probably
at a
an important time for schultz to
reassure both people in germany and
germany's allies abroad that uh he is
not missing in action that germany is
there and that it is also working
together with with its allies it's also
a time for charles to
show putin uh where germany stands at
the moment uh with the new government
until now only the foreign minister anna
lena berba met with her counterpart
lavrov in moscow
and uh we've we know that angela merkel
the previous chancellor had a good
working relationship with putin all
along so now it's time for olaf schultz
to show putin where he stands
well did schultz manage to clearly
communicate where he stands yesterday
he reiterated germany's position or his
government's position that it's held for
the last few weeks with a focus on
diplomacy schulz said that any violation
of ukraine's territorial integrity and
sovereignty will
have a high price tag something that
we've heard time and time again and he
said that germany is going to work as
hard as it can to
try to prevent any aggression from
russia and he also put a focus on
economic support for ukraine to try to
make ukraine as economically independent
as possible
there has been no mention of any
delivery of weapons or any other kind of
measure because the position of the
government is to not deliver weapons to
ukraine at the moment our political
correspondent julia sardelli there thank
you